tes propos si j'ose dire franchement ils
ont jeté un trouble et c'est des propos
en tout cas si on prétend être à l air
on ne peut pas faire d' accord de prêt
ou de loin avec le front national ou
avec une le pen qu'elle soit marion
qu'elle soit marine pense comment vous
moi un boulet pour finalement voté non
ils ont ils menti quand même non non ils
ont été virés non ils ont et non jeunes
hurlaient compris ils ont été victime
d'une diabolisation
voilà bien personne les a obligés à dire
alors ça mais obliger à dire à monsieur
b adresse que je suis bien je suis prêt
à faire une alliance avec marion
maréchal-le pen a ils ont été victimes
avant cela notamment on parlait du
trocadéro c'est pas eux qui ont organisé
le trocadéro c'est monsieur stefanini
d'ailleurs qui était le directeur de
campagne bien et aujourd'hui justement
les propos du président sont d'autant
plus comment dirais-je inconcevable que
il ne faut pas donner d'arguments et cet
argument d'une possible alliance est un
argument qu'on doit absolument réfuter
ou alors parce que le front national
trompe le peuple ne défend pas le peuple
et je pense qu'il ne saurait y avoir
d'alliance pas et l'air ou avec les
mouvements associés avec une forme ou
une autre du front national les choses
sont très très clairs
chacun l'a rappelé d'ailleurs ce
mouvement a fait ensuite un rectificatif
collectif pour dire qu' ils entendent
bien rester dans cette ligne là et ne
pas céder justement à ce type d'alliance
et pour moi c'était un point qui était
très important